قالت القوات الجوية الأوكرانية إنها ضربت
قاعدة جوية عسكرية روسية في شبه
جزيرة القرم الغربية اليوم تقول مصادر في
أجهزة الأمن السرية الأوكرانية إن القوات الأوكرانية
هاجمت نفس القاعدة في سبتمبر الماضي مما
تسبب في أضرار جسيمة بينما
تدعي أوكرانيا أنها دمرت
معقلًا روسيًا خلال عملية
داخل بلغراد الروسية.  المنطقة يوم الجمعة
تقول إن عددًا غير محدد من
القوات الروسية قُتلوا خلال
الهجوم عبر الحدود، كما
ورد أن أوكرانيا كانت تستهدف
المنطقة الروسية بالصواريخ
أفادت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية أن الجو الروسي دمر 10
صواريخ أوكرانية أطلقت على المنطقة يوم الخميس.
أنظمة الدفاع يقول الحاكم الإقليمي إن
شخصين أصيبا
بشظايا متساقطة. أرى عدة مناشدات على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من عائلات تقول إننا خائفون
ساعدونا في الذهاب إلى مكان آمن بالطبع
سنساعدنا وسنفعل كل ما
يعتمد على
انضمامنا إلينا الآن.  باربي نو من سي إن إن في
روما، أه باربي، صباح الخير، ما الذي
يمكنك إخبارنا به أكثر عن الضربات الأخيرة
على
بلغراد، نعم، أنت تعلم أنه أمر
مثير للاهتمام حقًا، وهذا يمثل حقًا نوعًا من
التغيير في الإستراتيجية هنا مع
قيام أوكرانيا بهذه الهجمات عبر الحدود الآن،
قالت المخابرات الدفاعية الأوكرانية أه الهيئة  في برقية أن لديهم
معلومات تفيد بأن
فريقًا رئيسيًا من القيادة العسكرية الروسية سيكون هناك
لإجراء عملية تفتيش عندما
نفذوا هذا الهجوم الذي يبدو أنه
ناجح تمامًا ولكن مرة أخرى، هذا هو ما
تعلمه أوكرانيا تشن
هجومًا مضادًا في هذه المرحلة والذي  هو
شيء يتغير مع
دخولنا العام الجديد والمرحلة الجديدة من
هذه الحرب في وقت لاحق الآن، ونفهم أيضًا
في تطور منفصل ولكن ذو
صلة أن حليفًا رئيسيًا لبوتين
يعرض إطلاق سراح الجنود الأوكرانيين الأسرى،
أخبرنا
بالمزيد، نعم  كما تعلمون، هناك
مشكلة ما في هذا الأمر، على الرغم من أن رام رمضان
قديروف، وهو زعيم الذقن، يقول
إنه إذا رفعت الولايات المتحدة
العقوبات عن زوجاته وابنته
وأطفاله، فإنه سيكون على
استعداد للإفراج عنهم.  هؤلاء الجنود الأوكرانيون العشرون
آه، كما تعلمون، وهو يقول
إن الولايات المتحدة يمكنها ذلك
إذا أرادت بالفعل تضخيم
العقوبات ضده، مما يضع
الولايات المتحدة في موقف صعب بعض الشيء
لأن هذه العقوبات
بالطبع كانت فعالة للغاية  فيما
يتعلق بالتأكد من أن هؤلاء
القادة لا يمكنهم القيام
بالأعمال المعتادة في جميع أنحاء أوروبا والولايات المتحدة،
ولذا يبقى أن
نرى كيف قد يكون
رد فعل الولايات المتحدة على هذا أه وما هو الضغط الذي
قد تمارسه أوكرانيا  عليهم أيضًا
رفع هذه العقوبات مقابل
هؤلاء الجنود الأوكرانيين العشرين ليا باربي ن
تقدم تقريرًا في روما شكرًا جزيلاً لك يا
باربي